how are you better than we deserve Dave
cool I mean you're committed you're here
from Kansas City in the middle of the
dadgum World Series wearing Royals
jerseys and you came to Dave Ramsey's
office anyway to do your debt-free
screen that's commitment
yeah they're both pretty important to us
that's pretty wild welcome thank you for
being here wow that's a that's a big
deal so you've been working on that
course this affects your life baseball
is just kind of fun so yeah you're not
actually going to get paid for watching
them not that I know of anyway all right
so how much debt have you paid off there
was a little over a hundred and forty
thousand dollars but we are here to
celebrate really the last 125 of that
because we did that in about 30 months
okay all right very cool and in 30
months making what kind of money she has
a variable income she's a nurse so our
income range from about 95 to 130 during
that time cool what do you guys do for a
living she's a nurse and you I'm a
project manager in healthcare I team
okay very cool good good so was that
last 125 the house no no all student
loans student loans okay so you kind of
got a little bit of other stuff knocked
out but then when you're really leaned
into it was 30 months ago well it was
all student loans yeah unfortunately we
went through financial peace in 2012 at
our church and my dad was teaching the
class and he really wanted us to come
and we had just got married the summer
before and we were a little reluctant I
didn't think that we needed it I knew
that we had a lot of student loan debt
but that we could manage it we went
through the class and we didn't really
start doing a budget and applying
ourselves the way that we needed to
until it was about a year later and I
thought oh boy we've been really
sacrificing we've been paying you know
like a thousand bucks a month on these
loans and we look back and we hadn't
made any progress at all so that was
when we decided okay it's time to
revisit some of this material and really
bear down or these things are gonna be
around forever
okay did you go back through the class
yes yeah we actually taught it okay well
that's a way that way you don't flunk it
yep way to go you - very cool so now as
a Financial Peace University coordinator
you've paid off 140 but 125 in the last
30 months and when people ask you how
did you do that what are the secrets to
getting out of that what do you tell
them well for me and none of this is
be surprised to you but for anybody
that's listening there's two really
things that stick out to me one is the
budget and that's what I really told all
of our class members that the written
budget is absolutely everything because
when we weren't doing the written budget
and giving every dollar a name we
weren't making any progress our money
was just escaping away from us but once
you assign a dollar name to every dollar
that's when you really start to make the
progress and another big thing is just
contentment you know we both need to
learn to just be content with what we
had and not try and keep up with the
Joneses and be content with ham
sandwiches for lunch and driving old
cars and just not needing to keep up
with the lifestyle that so many people
do that are in debt
Dana what do you say the secrets are
definitely hard work um you know
contentment and then we just realize you
you got to buckle down you just got to
do it because a lot of shifts as a nurse
said yeah a lot of extra hours a lot of
long 12-hour shifts a lot of time away
from my family but it's worth it because
now it's done yeah it's over forever you
never have to do that again yeah unless
you just decide to go back into debt or
something stupid like that but yeah
that's never have to do that again very
cool
what was the hardest part for you guys
I'm sure the hard work was part of it
mm-hmm for me I you know I think it was
just the everyday sacrifices of you know
not not doing things and learning to say
no but the one big thing that that
really hurt me was I did sell my truck
and we had I had it paid for before we
got married and so there wasn't any debt
on it but I looked at it as a big asset
that I could be transferring some of my
you know money from that truck towards
the loans so I went ahead and bit the
bullet earlier this year and right 15-6
was with the trucks
oh wow yeah and then I went ahead and
bought a little $1,900 car that I just
used to get around in oh my gosh that's
a big jump man yeah it was hard to give
up a truck and I missed it all the time
but you know to really speed up our
goals and get to this we sprint to the
finish line it was it was worth it I can
get another one well I mean you're
making a hundred thirty thousand a year
and you don't have any debt you know how
you can get a truck you know you'll pay
cash for it in no time
yep don't take any time at all with that
got you out that broke it looked broke
you lose very cool yeah so she's working
all those hours you give up your truck
that's how that works right yeah and I
did everything I could on the side to
you know I cut some lawns and I did
photography work when I could and some
videography here and there and you know
we tried to just pick up everything we
could we had garage sales and just
every single dollar that we could scrape
up we would just put straight towards
loans you guys were so game on did
anybody make fun of you yeah
and they still are yeah we've gotten a
lot of weird you know I mean you saw
that nice truck and move into that 1900
our car that right there I'll get you
going yeah that opened some eyes that's
I think that really told people when
these guys are serious but we are you
know I mean we've just decided that
that's not a tool that we're gonna use
in our lives and we never want anything
to do with it again yeah I absolutely
don't disagree a bit well way to go you
guys
and who's the young man oh this is
Hayley little gal okay I'm sorry yeah
she's in an area Cosmo Jersey but she's
yeah she's dressed like baseball so it
threw me I'm sorry my bad alright so
Hayley and she's how old 20 months all
right very cool about the same age as
one of my grandkids perfect all right
all right Evan and Dana from Kansas City
missing the not missing the World Series
tonight to be here to do their debt free
scream but they paid off 140,000 of
which 125 was done in the last 30 months
making 95 to 130 way to go you guys
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream all right here we go
three two one weird
way to go you guys absolutely awesome
man that's commitment right there you
know but you know they did everything
right
sold the truck work the extra jobs took
the extra hours did the budget realize
that wasn't working I went back through
the class to make sure they get the
information right boom man they did it
it's exactly what you do everything they
did was right
and you know what that means you know
what all those things weren't that none
of those things were miracles none of
those things were because they had a 4.2
GPA every one of those things were
because they made a choice that was
different they chose to live like no one
else so that later they can live and
give like no one else
you